square displays to speak its website aah
beat his face from a boat and get 10%
off they come to my dorm a space its
website website gone everything's all
right press page then the place to be
website
and the drummer from alone
tempis announcing come to my soul square
[Applause]
[Music]
we will have an organic funny
conversation now the podcasters start
welcome
so now that was over two hands a Rambler
with co-host Tony trim hellooo
sitting in with us today the hilarious
Chicago comic boxer jr. stop go hello
what up Junior Junior stop you because
you cuz I changed my voice yeah I just
do that for the intro can I go back to
talking good but I try to hype it up at
the beginning Thank You societies taught
me to be to do to be as an audio
personality
you don't you don't intro a comic like
alright you next time I know you gotta
get hype it up cuz I get it weird man
you start off weird I try I mean I start
off normal but then if things aren't
going well do not just delve into
weirdness I'll try to I'll try to fight
back but you just got a you you is who
you is gonna have that energy yeah talk
to the people talk to the PTA stir you
used to try to hate me up and be like
you gotta be the Asian Funk Flex I do
yeah sounds like a genre music I listen
to
oh hi pop Tony it's a man you gotta talk
to these people yell at them hype them
up which is awfully hard to do when
people are sitting down when you're like
DJing for a cop comedy crowd you're like
playing like some some hype [ __ ] you
ever play some funny songs like I like
this
yeah I mean sometimes but you know Eric
Andre when he was doing the Eric Andre
he wanted me to do like with an hours
notice wanted me to do all like TV show
theme songs uh-huh like Family Matters
and stuff like that
[Music]
Julie what'd you get into last night
I got into whiskey and Miller Lite
whiskey I'm really light yeah yeah
that's good is that a boilermaker I
think it is I don't know
diarrhea maker oh come on are you Bree
did you do a show last night
no I didn't I was fixing the car a
little bit fixing the car yeah I've
learned how to fix cars this past year
yeah yeah well you uh what are you
fixing on the car see I I have I got the
same model Honda Civic I had a shitty
one that I had for a long time so I'm
using that as my junk car and I'm just
replacing the parts from that one to
that one so I'm gonna try to put in
cruise control into this function o KU
control and as you know when you're
doing long road trips what you put in
cruise control on the car yeah yourself
by myself
well I bought the bananas make fun I
bought the car for five hundred bucks
off a bus boy yeah yeah oh yeah the
Honda you was talking about right in the
Civic right that's right oh one you said
no double zero man righto Parrish damn
2000 Honda Civic put the cruise control
on it so you got to build a button into
the goddamn stairs
how you gonna put it on cruise they got
buttons inside factory made ones that
have cruise control so I gotta do is go
to junkyard get the buttons there get
the harness boom that's way too much
work for just control why don't you just
put your foot on the pedal
I can lazy ya how lazy do I wanna be the
way you're doing a lot of work to be
lazy yeah I guess so that's true isn't
that what a house is yeah I guess yeah
we're getting the houses you work hard
so you could be comfortable in your
house and chill or you work hard you get
the house and then you kind of bird it
by the house and you always spending
your time outside the house trying to
get money to keep the house so you don't
have to now we're getting deep here man
yes what that's all life is is to work
really hard as hard as you can so you
could
nothing later so life is just a big K
hole ketamine ketamine whole ketamine
you ever do ketamine no I don't know
what is that horse tranquilizer
it's animal tranquil it's cat
tranquilizer catch the form I guess you
could I guess it comes in all different
forms for different animals but the kind
that we do that makes us all trippy is a
it's cat tranquilizers that's right boys
yeah like what you're supposed to do to
you it's like it makes you feel like oh
wow it's really it's hard to describe
makes you feel all like wobbly some of
sometimes it makes you hallucinate
something called the K hole that you
fall into if you do too much it's like
your vision is like it's like a tunnel
vision it's like seeing everything
through a little hole and you just can't
move and you burnt like you could see
yourself acting this way but you your
brain and your body just don't work
together no more so you're watching
yourself walk like a jackass so you know
you look stupid yeah yeah that's not you
look and sound stupid if I'm supposed to
make you feel cool doesn't it this one
doesn't this one doesn't make you feel
cool at all after-school special
yeah man that's uh from the Hanson
Rambla podcast don't do ketamine no if
you do ketamine just just a little bit
smidgen yeah do a smidgen just do a
smidgen do a what's that called when
you're cooking a pinch but you don't
know what the actual measurement - - -
just thought - what a - Academy of
poverty is tricking me cat
to drink it with me why don't wanna look
at it see I don't wanna compete I paid
$5.00 bars we just make songs on here
bars bars spittin bars can you rap jr.
now not at all I'm trying but I better
do did you do drugs drugs and stuff and
don't you can do it too if you're cool
like me yeah don't do it it stays cool
listen to your teachers unless she's a
[ __ ] I don't yeah it's pretty good like
it I liked it use some improvement a
little bit but am i off fair goddess
with you know I appreciate on here no
jay-z I'll tell you that much no no I
came out with a rap song but I never
released it really yeah when I was
probably around maybe five six years ago
yeah yeah head very crude lyrics and I
decided it was not yeah we can we really
can we release it here as a exclusive ye
I think I already released it
technically so it's probably out there
this is really awful song what are you
doing you stopped the song it's called
easy does it
after easy okay but it's it's called the
throw a cup of jizz in her face it's not
a good song what that's what's cool yeah
throw a couple of jizz yeah throw a
whole cup which is hard cuz yeah how
many dudes just to make a cup of jizz
but that's gonna take that the proper
you probably take a bottle right so I
thought that a week they'll be depends
on what type of cup you're talking about
but that's a lot of masturbation
hydration it's is pornos really fool you
cuz you think you could do a cup in like
an hour but not gonna happen
yeah you ever see a big dude coming in
Pawnee who does this guy think he is
this guy takes is better who do you
think you are man what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] that ain't real bro
you've been saving up all special
effects oh you got the goddamn Star Wars
people in here working on you did
huh [ __ ] out of here man yeah yeah why
does this why don't they have awards for
special effects porn man you know they
need an award for that too
you can't just have bus head in a movie
yeah best special effects they got some
I've been I went to the point of Wars I
was at AVN's last year it's fascinating
to watch people give speeches about anal
oh and I would like to thank my crew my
co-star for ramming my ass all
thoroughly and being very compassionate
and great to work with it's a straight
face like no yeah yeah if any any time
in your life Oh somebody roll with it
it's gonna explode no it's a good song
but any time you never see like a guy I
just like to thank myself and that's it
that would be a good time at the porn
Awards cuz yeah this is me hydrated
hydrated for this I wanted this forever
I would like to thank it was it was
great man the porn Awards were good
vibes it was it was they put me up up
front
I have front-row seats uh-huh yeah he
shot some of the big stars it's also the
big stars there saw Dana Deerman was in
my row ron jeremy is he still around
he's still around
my fellow gathering of the Juggalos
alumni ron jeremy we did the gig
together gathering of the Juggalos 2010
whoa yeah I went up and then Ron Jerry
went up I didn't watch his set because
they were eager to take me to the merch
tent but I should have stuck around and
watched his set well he does stand up he
was doing stories or stand-up yeah this
was hmm
I mean yeah thank you to gathering of
the Juggalos for that that that gig at
the time was the
most uh I got paid for one show really
yeah it was four then it was I was
really excited to get that offer hunter
that out your agent just said you upset
wanna do I think they tried to get
somebody else that was ripped by my
agent at a time I think they were trying
to book Rob Schneider or somebody that's
what a lot that's a lot of [ __ ] happens
is that somebody's not available and
then yeah they just the agent says I got
this guy for you or that's how I've
gotten something I've gotten some movies
like that where the original person that
they wanted for the movie can't do it
anymore who's that who's the guy they
wanted before you for who do you go in
roles with yeah well one movie I think
they want to Craig Robinson because it
said in the script it was like you're
stating Craig Robinson in the script it
said the character is he's the handyman
and then in parentheses it Craig
Robinson so your role was to act like
Craig Robinson know my role is to bring
this [ __ ] that I bring
oh and like no but but you know is is
just that's how it goes sometimes you
know we'll switch your agent was like
can you get a little fatter a little bit
can you also learn how to play keyboard
beyond offices great dude he's a great
dude hilarious and yeah just fun to kick
it with you know you know Will Smith
danced on the matrix what will Smith was
supposed to be in the maitre de Ben in a
matrix and he passed on it right went to
Keanu Oh will smoke was supposed to be
neo
Will Smith could have been neo he could
have been a billionaire down
well I get it now there's a bunch of
stuff like that you sign up you a
Scientologist or am I crazy
somebody told me that one time I don't
know but yeah be really crazy we don't
speak about them on this
okay I love you all this is very this is
a new production man we don't [ __ ]
around let us get our footing man before
we start getting into that I love all
religion now we all know do you know
they got they got oh they own all the
bandwidth on the Internet yeah when we
talk about gangs on here you don't talk
about gang gang nah nah
when the last time Neutron you've been
in a fight recently Julian no I haven't
been in a fight in a long time last one
was a guy threw a bottle I think I told
that story it's robot like me it was
white guy with dreadlocks doing a set
yeah what will you it it was like this
show I don't know if you know this guy
he booked it was like an alderman kind
of a it's it's for the young kids of the
community
oh they booked you they booked me
because why I have no idea why would you
book me for a community
thing but it was weird let's pay good as
a paid gig there was music there was
artists drawing on the wall will you
know the comedian on the gig there were
two comics first comic ate it
Oh bad and I went I want my money now
bad stage yeah cuz I'm not going up on
as I get paid here cuz I ain't waiting
around here what time was your slot it
had to be like 10th it was like two or
three bands yeah nobody was paying
attention
yeah kids walk it looked like a Foot
Clan party that's the best way I could
describe it it was like an arcade here
you know guys wearing a headband over
here and then okay and then two comics
cut through the back your inner self
annotate the Foot Clan and you can't you
can't entertain it for you in stores out
there those never see junior life that's
what the story is but yes so the I start
going
somebody said fine I in the middle I
kindly got him to pay attention finally
well what joke did you start with though
Oh
I try to get I try to get weird in the
beginning but this one I was just
yelling because everyone was going ah
you couldn't nobody isn't paying
attention at first so I forgot like five
people to pay attention then I got like
10 and then 20 then finally I can eat it
was like 30 to really just get the show
going finally I got that and it one of
the band guys I don't know if using the
bangs just kept shouting radishes radish
like he was trying to heckle but he
couldn't be funny oh it's out of my hair
clean if it's funny whatever you know
but this one was any second city
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up yeah that
say that sometimes to the folks yeah
this ain't Second City they say whose
line is it anyway there
this ain't ImprovOlympic [ __ ]
man ask for no sir just honest back to
my material exactly what I do
so then [ __ ] ups I just marked making
fun of his dreadlocks I go look Oh a
white guy was just wow I go what's wrong
with this this is nice doesn't smell
like [ __ ] in the hairspray oh okay and
then now where's the crowd with as far
as oh they're laughing at oh yeah I'll
[ __ ] yeah and you can't have that room
bottle flew by the bottle
yeah and I didn't even say anything I
just went over their song at them then
yeah we got into a kerfuffle and then
the guy who booked me wait wait wait you
said you swung Adam did you connect I
didn't connect loudly oh just do the
fighter no probably not just you were
driving away I'm always drunk he's
backed away but then I got him a couple
of times in the kerfuffle and then my
friend came back on said he goes you
guys have been part of an Andy Kaufman
in the guy who booked me said that yeah
so then I left I got $40 though how long
was your set before the bottle Oh
probably I was probably about 12 minutes
in or something like that
oh [ __ ] that's a salt man he assaulted
yeah yeah that's called a salt
anytime somebody assaults you turn the
other cheek and just punch at him cuz
you don't do that you know you can't be
turning cheeks man you only got two
cheeks that's right never turn both
cheeks turn two cheeks you ever tried
one up Jesus turn both cheeks mm-hmm a
long time cheeks across Chin's questions
come through drinking gin
where'd you started working with
Stanhope that was Doug Stanhope
Doug's town by the way Doug Stanhope
podcast can i plug that yeah listen to
it is good I'm on it all right
very infrequently because I I'm not good
at podcast so anyway I was in Chicago I
think it was probably at the lakeshore
something like that and he was there and
I was like man whatever that people had
their separate rooms I thought the
headliner had their separate room and I
was supposed to stay back in the kids
table
because it was always like three or four
comics hanging around yeah and the
headline is in the secret private
headliner room but like he came out hey
you guys got any merch and I'm like I'm
like a few years then I go I'm not even
that good he was real nice dude he like
I guess he liked me like so that's how
we met yeah
and we drink a lot we're good we're
friends yeah so he's taking you on the
road I got a game with you yeah I got a
gig with him in Boston April 6 how about
that April 6 where it Boston somewhere
okay I'm we're in Boston check out Doug
Stanhope junior stop good April 6 Wow
Boston boss
that's my Boston accent but I'm bad at
Bastin yeah we went to Boston jizz
Patriots all day as Red Sox the Celtics
are doing well and it's just I'm just
excited to be from Boston right now
that's the worst I like that it's just a
great place we are decidedly a place
full of educational institutions we got
we got a basketball player we need
somebody to compliment Isiah Thomas
ha ha ha ha ha Boston Celtics go into
the playoffs
I felt good I can relate vocal warm-ups
yeah it's a good word vocal warm-ups
vocal warm-ups how long you been doing
community communities tell me they come
a disease summit day today goodbye daddy
how long you been don't come a day today
I just landed on an alien planet and I'm
listening to you community
we need a translator for this one hello
and how do you even do you start it
today I mean I did it I started it I
started comedy you started comedy
started comedy and I started it there
was a guy does a guy fell I started
pointing and laughing at him and people
went holy [ __ ] yeah this is something
new everyone's been copying me since
nice included me no not you you got your
own thing the original you got Carlin
Pryor and comedy Carla right so you
stopped so he stopped that's a good list
of comics right thank you
fold it in high school vote it most
likely to put cruise control of his own
that's true that's true yeah you uh you
we order debating no I don't think
something bad no were you at ROTC no
were you in sports I made the basketball
team but I quit what that's right why
you could have been John packs man yeah
it could have been John Paxson but I
wanted to be like I wanted to be more
like will not will Purdue I guess was
that guy he saw hot dog voices no no I
said I was his name Bill Laimbeer no no
no bill Weddington there you go Oh game
Bogut the dollar bill once Bill
Weddington that guy what have you liked
Bill Whittington yeah man he saw hot
dogs at McDonald's that's hard to do
what you know remember that no
McDonald's had hot dogs and he sold them
you lose the pitchman yeah you know how
hard you have to be a basketball player
and sell hot dogs at McDonald's you're
not hard of a job yeah they just called
it the weddington right I think they
called it something like that and then
Dennis Rodman had a cup and if you put
Coca Cola in it his hair color would
change from green to another color and
then Jordan had the McRib well they
called it the McGeorge but it was just
magrib that's really deep testament to
how much the Bulls were crushing it yeah
in fact then that the backup Center had
a hot dog named that day that's exactly
impressive yeah
so keep Noah didn't had no hot dog named
after him I'm getting more DeRose didn't
even have him didn't even have a nugget
I thought Joakim Noah was a star myself
turned to Rose era I saw I just saw this
documentary about the the Florida teams
University of Florida team which one the
ones that wanted two back-to-back
championships but he was always our
Horford and Corey Brewer yeah and
there's a part in it that shows them
announcing that they're gonna stay
another year after they won a
championship
it was speculation where they were gonna
go to the NBA and then these guys
decided to stay they made an
announcement where they decided to stay
another year in college presumably
because they probably just like easy
college [ __ ] I get it and Joakim is
this part where he he said we just
decided we he's talking to camera and he
said imagine that night we just
announced that we was staying there
imagine that night he just kept saying
that imagine that night imagine that
night like a so we get it you've
probably had a threesome son right he's
imagined that night drugs sex ask our
what if it was just like a bunch of
dudes with them imagine that night just
so many high fives everybody else is
like I kinda want to forget that night
imagine that night we play Mortal Kombat
6 a.m. I use Jack's every time
[Laughter]
it's hard to play with Jax who's your
favorite Mortal Kombat character I guess
raiden raiden raiden raiden is too slow
for me but he does that he was the first
to make they that stupid yell cool
what yell no man Ryu was the one that
had the first stupid great Nats of
longer yells yeah here's were extended
who's that that's still Ryu
we just laid out later on that was later
our way got longer yeah no that was a
saint that was a spinning kick that's
not only originals yeah that's on them I
guarantee you ratings yells longer all
right we'll put it on there we'll put it
on here we'll put it on here do it [ __ ]
it you get what you get
yeah we don't get what you get when we
give them what we give you know how we
live this is how we do
another day with the hairs and bramlett
crews on 94.3 every Wednesday from 94.3
to 95.7 yeah what's the next move would
you sing the voice and your jokes
you need a car repair show I do yeah
yeah I was thinking about it you could
do a car repair show but we never fixed
a car I just say you don't need to do
this just just get in the car yeah why
oh you want me to yeah wait
did you see my hands they're bleeding
from trying to fix his [ __ ] he's a car a
combat car repair so can we do it Henry
flips got a funny cooking show and I'm
sorry it's a real cooking show but he's
very funny go check it out Henry's
kitchen by the way Henry's kids it
Google I remember one night me and you
were talking food for like three hours
yeah I'm I like to cook I like to cook I
like to grow three hours on foot
remember that we were at the UH it was
three are maybe that might be a little
comic exaggeration maybe a little comic
it was a long time though
it was probably good what are you going
should we talk food for so long that
like I remember Hannibal was just like
you two should just have your own little
food podcast well we do some people are
passionate about food yeah
what worry Tom but we were talking about
like the perfect hot dog or something
yeah that makes okay so what makes a
perfect hot dog junior perfect hot dog
you gotta start with all 100% beef
sausage it's gotta be Vienna though has
to be Vienna yeah that's the best one
Vienna beef who's better than Vienna
wait y'all were having as long as food
discussion and he laminated by hot dogs
right it started with hot dogs and then
we moved over to polish Maxwell Street
oh oh okay so you know I'm saying
do you like a Maxwell Street can we say
what a Maxwell Street is yeah it's a
sign you eat it
yeah okay we got that out of the way
yeah
what's your fate what you like mustard
sometimes not all the time but I'll get
into it sometimes but I'm not when
you're really into it you gotta have
mustard on the Polish yeah come on I
think that's the only time we're really
in a mustard is for polishes me too
I'd say the same thing yeah sausage and
mustard I don't know what other thing
you can put on it onions no I meant like
as far as mustard what else use mustard
for besides a hot dog pretzels pretzels
I don't is man you put cheese on pretzel
got some sandwiches sandwiches a little
dijon on there it's delicious yeah but
you don't taste you know you want that
sandwich you know mustard is just like
in the way kind of you want that
sandwich please delicious but it's gotta
be the star yeah you're right you're
right it can't be competing with ketchup
I don't like yeah you can't be competing
nothing can compete with ketchup ketchup
takes over ketchup takes over the whole
room they're like ketchup came in on
this podcast you hear nothing but
ketchup listen y'all need to stop
letting this ketchup have this amount of
power over you in my opinion if you
asking me personally I think ketchup is
overrated but that's just I I think it's
ridiculous that the Heinz company has
such a large market share of the ketchup
business they can't be doing anything
that incredible versus a store brand or
other brands of ketchup but I can't even
off the top of my head
name another brand of ketchup I got two
hunts hunts yeah hunt and then hunts
that's it that's the only competitor at
all
it's not that no it's just ketchup as
ketchup it's never bad you've never been
all yeah this gets up is so different
what's your snack a choice now younger
comics dreams the advice for me coming
up any tips on how to influence I am
going to start doing that
[Music]
squarespace.com
from moco cannibal get a great website
what are you doing
make a symbol for yourself what are you
doing
fix it sleek websites they've been doing
it for a while they're obviously
successful I mean the fact that this is
giving me money to talk about it means
that they're doing all right
they have disposable income
squarespace.com promo code Hannibal get
10% off your first purchase yeah
[Music]
I haven't I've been to I'm two weeks and
that drinking man two weeks not drinking
all of [ __ ]
five weeks off the booze two weeks no
boom two weeks is that 14 days there's
that 1314 day exactly exactly yeah I
thought Minneapolis was gonna break you
it's just wrong huh I didn't break me
man it did not it didn't even get close
I feel you got close once you feel
better I do you feel real good feel
sharp feel sharp no hangovers I wake up
smooth mm-hmm
I got a clarity I feel quicker slimmed
down don't have greasy puffy face that's
true and uh yeah man I'm ready to fight
anybody gonna be getting those Craig
Robinson rolls if you keep doing it I'm
not gonna get oh yeah I'm gonna get some
karate rose let me get some action rolls
you can you can you do karate have you
ever done any action in a movie like you
car exploded but they cut it out or
something
actually in uh in the first neighbors
they have a scene where they shoot
fireworks into my car mm-hmm
but they have a stunt man in their car
crashes but did you ask to do it where
you get what you like Tom Cruise I want
to do my own nah cuz it wouldn't even
have been that dope yeah yeah it
wouldn't have been one of the one it's
not like flipping and fighting and
jumping off of some stuff it's just it's
somewhere they wouldn't have seen if I
was driving a car anyways it's just but
you know I'm just trying to I could see
Hannibal karate being a good movie this
is name of the movie Hannibal karate
Hannibal karate yeah you know what you
know what cuz you're laid back so this
would be very interesting because nobody
could see you they'd be all this then
right yeah cuz you know I that will be
great um if I'm just talking with
another character and they telling me
something bad that happened to friends
or people that I care about and
dammit god dammit I gotta go do some
karate on these mother title sequels
Hannibal karate get to work on the
trailer
gotcha I got you karate that's a good
movie what's your movie Junior junior
karate do any karate junior karate say
movies just a ripoff it's like the VHS
version yeah yours is like do the movie
good action movies have to have three
words like mark for death out for
justice so you guys got to come up with
a three word it doesn't have a three
word yeah that that Hannibal karate is
like horrible karate as discernible
karate man Hannibal karate meant
Hannibal correct karate yeah you should
get an action figure first then make the
movie that's how the Ninja Turtles
started really yeah whatever car chase
that you come up with a title first and
then make the movie come up with the
action figure first then make the movie
a la Ninja Turtles Oh what about come up
with the title first and then make the
movie no no no the title no you
misunderstand you make the title first
then you make the movie then you make
the action figure and then you make the
money and then you get the girls I'm
down with it man I agree it's got it is
time for a change also there could be a
love scene have you had a love scene yet
I've had a few yeah yeah this guy's
getting it all via a beef a [ __ ] fake
[ __ ] that could be the new rom-com oh
yeah
fake [ __ ] [ __ ] man start jr. one
of the silver stones Alicia Alicia
Silverstone and the guys that a real
person yeah this girl from clueless yeah
she is
I thought I made that up it just sounded
natural good that's good but fake
[ __ ] that's great actually that
instinct is great and I want you just
roll with it I want you to be
okay the lead writer on Hannibal karate
I could write I got the script ready one
great instinct I just I just wanted to
leave my script Hannibal karate here I
didn't really have much else to say this
is my favorite podcast
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
was that the only time you've had some
thrown at you or been attacked on stage
cuz I know you're very funny guy but I
you're not for everybody
no it's fair to say so I could imagine
you being in some situations where your
car repair people shout at me what they
shout stop what you're doing yeah it's
basically what they stop it yeah I'm
talking yeah yeah yeah stop performing
on stage stop doing comedy who is this
guy yeah I've had that too as anybody
but after the show today confronts you
never know it's just in the time you
know what people do they heckle and then
afterwards like you were great you
forget that you were great man and I go
I don't like you
yeah I don't like when hecklers try to
buy me a drink you need to come up to me
as if we're buddies like we're a comedy
team or something let's do a shot no
first of all I'm getting shots for free
second of all I don't want to drink with
you you suck and you interrupted me and
you made it so I wasn't able to have
enough time to get to my joke about all
the peaceful non panicky shits that I
I've been taking that's what been one
thing about non panicky shits really
well lately because I haven't been
drinking
uh-huh oh you can't [ __ ] right no I
should right but you better [ __ ] better
because you know liquor give you
diarrhea no in the morning and stuff but
that's only because you shitty food with
it no liquor destroys your day yeah but
listen like if you're so if you're sober
you're not gonna go to a taco joint it
three I'm going oh let me get a whole
burrito hand side of rice and I eat
terribly yeah that terribly but I still
get fried food and late-night stuff in
order delivery and nothing all of my
[ __ ] composed regulome
shit's no like I gotta go yeah it's
always a I'm going to take this [ __ ] I
[ __ ] on my terms on my terms
okay I am taking control I might be the
funnest person to hang out with just
constantly taking what do you call him
again a key panicky Hannah keys [ __ ]
thank you shits panicky shits is a
nineteen twenties actor very jealous of
Charlie chat is panicky [ __ ] people
don't know who was the cast it was they
would stay was Charlie Chaplin that hey
you know he had to have some haters of
course
Fatty Arbuckle really [ __ ] hated a
man
Fatty Arbuckle wanna kick this [ __ ] out
of them Fatty Arbuckle nobody like fatty
though
oh why there's so many Polish people in
Chicago Chicago has the lizard Chicago
has the largest yeah oldest population
outside of Warsaw Poland that's true
what happened they just really like
house music they do yeah no that's true
very very very big Polish I don't know
you know well back in the devil Bucktown
was was all Paul it was all every I'm
pretty sure yeah I don't know what the
hell happened I still don't know I guess
it was the meat industry yeah we needed
workers killing animals so that's what
assassin just came France right well
that's German
and then I don't know what we
contributed what do you what do you
prefer the Polish sausage of the German
sausage you know I like a good I like a
good Italian sausage you know what I
mean
got you cuz of a spice yeah I like a
spicier one I like a sopressata you ever
had that one now yeah salami sopressata
Sasha
cooter Eman Chuck cooter ease get a
little that with a mutt with some
mustard most stars I'm crostinis can you
do an Italian voice was amazing that was
amazing
yeah oh no turn that up turn up turn up
sure that ship that cut that don't cut
that put it that cut this part cut this
part but this what it's a county there's
a stop everywhere that Tony paused this
part really not press play cut that part
right now okay cut it
did you cut that one yeah all right
press pause pause all right not play
right all right
pressure court we got it we got it
it's my editing skills right there bada
ba ba boom I just did some cells with
Chris Rock this weekend ooh in
Minneapolis in Milwaukee they they said
welcome ladies and gentlemen number
three in your minds number seven in your
hearts please welcome animal birds and
not hit that stage and I told them jokes
and it went well
sounds like Devil Went Down to Georgia
but with comedy yeah exactly and that
stage yeah I get out stage the mayor of
Minneapolis what a outstanding fantastic
gig I'm happy to witness that
I'm happy to have done it now is the
trip meant actually didn't watch any of
Chris's sets I just kind of got caught
up in my own world did dipped out I
didn't get to see him it was great man
it was uh he's in the third week of his
tour he's having different openers in a
lot of the cities Eric Andre's done so
I'm Ali Wong think Janel James Chris
Spencer was hosting these shows that I
was on so it was cool to see him work
out man he's really meticulous about it
and you know he runs through every cent
and and you know you know tinkers it
figures out the word in and so uh it was
it was a good learning experience to see
to see the process he's very very chill
dude man does he have an entourage uh is
a people that they got guns I can't
speak on that nobody know that I saw
though guns he had nobody with guns I
want to get a guy with a protect me with
a gun isn't that like the biggest move
you can make ever if a guy with a gun is
protecting you you made it yeah yes a
lot of times a lot of times it doesn't
even have to be a guy in a suit though
a lot of times you don't need that know
if it's so it's more of a status symbol
than actual protection something like
some people need actual security yeah
jay-z Beyonce yes they need security and
then security is actually from when I
seen him out is pretty light is just one
dude that is huge guy one huge one guy
about six six guy and he's with them
he's been with them for years I think
you'll see if you see pictures of their
and see the same dude and he handles it
pretty chill where I asked him if you
have a
it was one time at the SNL 40 party I
asked him I say you have had to rough
anybody up and he said if you ever have
to rough somebody up you already lost I
was like oh [ __ ] oh he's on some
high-level security [ __ ] yeah damn Tony
Robbins obscenities masterminds like you
know you need to know you if you have to
rough somebody up no you mean like he
could stop a threat before it even
stopped stuff before yeah you know
preventative preventive preventive
bodyguarding yeah that type of that
makes sense yeah you can't
yeah you can't whip out the gun right
away if a guy wants up for an autograph
yeah he can't whip out the gun you can't
be pistol whipping people well what's
that thing a blackjack two had that
thing
oh this Mexican guy in the back of the
head I think that's Chuck Norris is that
Chuck Norris yeah he's got to be seven
jean-claude Van Damme fat damn I like
man name would you rather have a big a
big bodyguard with a gun
mm-hmm or a little bodyguard little
bodyguard Oh awesome like katana blades
a little bodyguard
I want a little bodyguard that can't
even fight that's what I want
oh yeah cuz it'll be funny we pay a guy
to get his ass kicked and hang out with
you battle dress him up nice
Louis Abed you look you would you put a
nice hat on them look here was work it
out then your bodyguard getting his ass
beat then people know that your
operation is vulnerable game alone
that's what I'm gonna say when they kick
his ass let them along give them a
little head
yeah you'd be adorable bodyguard
how come bodyguards gotta be tougher I
can't they'd be cute and adorable
sometimes what your needs are that's
true
yours is purely entertainment my yeah
mine is full entertainment I heard that
it's not possible to actually be a
spider-man just because of the humans
humans can't do it technically if you
combine the DNA of a human and a spider
yeah that embryo zygote will be
terminated immediately it can't grow so
I'm impossible yeah I don't know I think
it's thought I mean if it's a
radioactive spider radioactive maybe cuz
you're out yeah well now no uranium in
there now you're adding different stuff
right yes imagine dragons that welcome
to do radioactive I saw was unavoidable
and now it's totally avoidable it was
funny how music works well we like this
now we're now not know mode that was
like always the background music for
like fighting clip calm polite and clear
of sport how long how long does a song
have before it's redundant it depends on
the song that's all got license for a
lot of stuff so they definitely milk the
[ __ ] out of it and it was a huge song
and they got a lot of money out of it
cuz he was on lots of [ __ ] but now you
don't hear no more mm-hm it had his run
that's a good thing I need to make a hit
like that no no that they can't use that
let's make up let's make up a sports hit
like a sports like John Tesh John Tesh
dead nnnn
[Music]
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it do
it
sports sports sports we're gonna do it
nothing [ __ ] outta you we're gonna knock
you not gonna [ __ ] outta you
da-da-da-da-da-da winner teamwork we got
the team word but up put a little
teamwork synergy energy energy energy
teamwork synergy energy I like that
that's energy energy energy
[Music]
you might have it that's good we gotta
aim for football no that's good money
right there
[Music]
[ __ ] out there
fauna the store the enemy
[Music]
everybody with me and I got a lot of
energy destroyed the enemy are you a
friend of means energy energy
I like the little beats at the end hello
I got hit we got a hit on our hands help
maybe stop this podcast stuff it just
fit my time we'll try to make hits I
think so mm-hmm
I think I got yeah this podcast is fun
but I think I think the Lord was
something bigger for me are you - I
think these energy I think Jesus has got
bigger plans
mm-hmm yeah synergy and energy let's
just pray on it what that's the holy
spirit energy holy spirit the holy
spirit did God
let's say a prayer you got we come to
you today synergy Hansen regular podcast
with Tony trim and special guest Julia
stop the hosted by Hannibal Buress
episode who knows thank you Lord for the
moderate success that the podcasters
have thank you for the food that we eat
right before we do this podcast and also
thank you for the liquor that my guests
are usually hung over all when they
perform all the podcast so thank you for
the stories that you've given us Jesus
Christ but this has been a fun time but
now I would like to be a legendary hit
maker so please God let it be in your
plans for me to make twenty million
dollars in licensing on ESPN from US
energy energy song amen through Jesus
Christ amen
our Lord that was good prayer man it's
good I think you got you gotta say to
Jesus I don't know yeah yeah you might
actually a religious person and not even
know it
that's not like very believable prayer
oh man he's praying for real people just
say let's start prayer cuz you just like
all right especially when you got all
that food in front of you yeah Oh like I
want that food this is pray okay cool
we're holding hands now all right cool
let's thank the Lord for this food
what is the last time you did a show I
did a show at
was it north Oh my friend oh nice yeah
my friend died that did his funeral oh
man yep
anyway I feel bad that no I was joking
okay I thought you had your bowels under
control yeah that's they can undergo I
didn't show it I waited to do that I did
a show yeah that's fun I ripped a lot
it's good I give myself a b-plus what's
the way you bout to get into man you
know what I really want to get into what
cheese-making she's ready yeah making
cheese making cheese it's about making
money
yeah that's not right or making cheese
or making cheese making cheese making
that will make your cheese will make a
cheese that's right what about bread you
trying to make bread too well you got to
put something on it what are you gonna
put that's a lot that's good man you got
a good aspiration thank you I'm trying
to get it to cheese make I want to get I
want to make a new cheese there's not
enough out there yeah there's a really
kind of cheese what kind of cheese
cheddar good year okay yeah how you
spell it how you saying you're a very
gray area gray area no Jer great
yeah yeah hey how come we can't have a
cheese that's blue like actual blue not
blue cheese that's not blue I want all
blue there's Chuck uniform I want a
piece little ooh you want a piece of boo
yeah that's a food coloring situation no
you could do it if you mix it correctly
with the mold you're not supposed to eat
mold because of politics or whatever
don't be one of those guys that rip
people off with the Swiss cheese mat
fill those holes up I agree with not
missing cheese I think that [ __ ] I -
just give me a regular slice don't give
me no [ __ ] holes in my cheese yeah I
gotta do this and now it's and now
there's no holes in it it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you ever get a colonic
no I got a colonic once uh-huh no no
colano
it was I was I was looking like that
[ __ ] was in me uh-huh
whoa now is this some Hollywood party or
was this like at an actual doctor the
first time would be a weird-ass party
yeah well no they were wearing masks
[ __ ] each other the first time it was
at Chelsea Peretti's party she had a
colonic party and that's just a normal
thing yeah and then and in the second
times it Bob Saget's place Bob Saget you
know me and Bob Saget we used jet ski a
lot and then I wasn't into just getting
too much anymore crap you had to ask him
they had a falling out you got to ask
him you know we played poker together
and I guess he got upset about the
amount of times I would have a man was
partying on a road like with Stanhope
every day is a blessing y'all wear some
weird suits he may y'all have a uniform
we technically have uniform yes
goofy suits we do goofy suits we go on
the road with thrift store yeah and we
go to goofy other places and if we see a
goofy stuff we buy it we wear that and
we own it
on stage off stage and in life nice it's
a good philosophy thank you
seems like he's very spontaneous person
you know what sometimes just like an
[ __ ] and you'll have fun yeah
sometimes you have to you get into the
vibe of your clothes like I would never
wear leather pants I would if I was
trying to be an [ __ ] did you have you
worn leather pants or never that's the
next step it's gotta be I'm going with
pleather pleather with zippers that's
right with one jacket more zippers on
zippers everywhere yeah zipper pockets
um I'll do it yeah if you can if I can
rock that some earrings mmm big coupe
ones though big hoop earrings that's
making a comeback with the NBA now
instead of the one earring like Jordan
they're doing the big hoop ones yeah
it's hard because I love Tina ones yeah
yeah how do you play basketball with
those are on very carefully yeah you
just stay light on your feet and you
just talk to God when you need them you
talk to them and talk back he say what
the [ __ ] do you know
a book well
[Music]
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] about while
you pray and thank us sleepless chicken
and grits I got that it was the [ __ ]
Oh God [ __ ] your food I got out of stuff
that you don't talk to her
God but out of his stop bothers which
[ __ ] back to me that above God use a
[ __ ]
thanks man I like that one that was a
good one that was a you know is that
good way for a break right there I think
I wanna smoke yeah are you having a
nicotine all right seriously that is a
good point that was a [ __ ] good song
Tony
yeah cut this part out all right all
right
yeah should we take a break yeah let's
take a break all right all right we're
rolling go nice all right we're back
from break with with Julia yeah yeah yep
yeah and that's the show man that's the
show that's the end of the show thanks a
lot Junior
Thank You Man shoutout to my sponsor
mods for Tots all right apple juice
I sell juice to children go and check us
out share subscribe that's it
[Music]